Now this is a good example of what we learned in lesson one, that different
psychologists have different view points or perspectives in terms of how they
explain behavior and sometimes they're very passionate about those view points.
Now throughout the course we discuss the importance about nature and nurture in
learning. And it's also important to hear when we're looking at how we learn to
comprehend and to produce language. The social cultural theory of language
suggests that things such as schooling, our peers, birth order, socioeconomic
status and our parents all contribute to our language development. And we know
that imitation is important and you should remember that from the lesson on
learning. An interesting example of imitation, did you know that infants as
young as 50 minutes old will open their mouths and stick out their tongues when
they see adults do. That's pretty powerful.